die qualität von geliefertem essen hängt
von zwei faktoren ab von dem essen und
der lieferung werde ich meine privaten
favoriten habe gibt es doch eine relativ
große vielfalt von lieferservices
deshalb habe ich mir gedacht was sind
die besten restaurants bei den
verschiedenen lieferservices und ich
finde nach bewertung und bestellt
jeweils beim allerersten restaurant
immer wenn man denkt jetzt gemacht dass
das ein unser erster kandidat heißt
wollt ihr seht ihr jetzt eine seite
eingeblendet wir filtern ganz klassisch
nach bewertungen zack zack bumm nun mit
vital bestellbar udo vegan wiegen fein
ist 25 bis 50 minuten lieferzeit 9,6 auf
10 möglichen punkten sehr selbst franck
haben jetzt ein bisschen runter gehen
seht ihr schon es gibt noch weitere
restaurants mit 9,64 die lassen aber
außer acht weil die einfach davon aus
das passt ganz oben ist so entweder
zahlen die halt drauf oder sie sind 9,69
beispielsweise einfach vielleicht ein
bisschen besser besucher wieder
irgendwas auf worauf ich lust habe wir
schauen einfach mal oben besteck und
behälter menüs unglücks für 2 47 90
unterwegs für 371 90 alter schwede guck
mal überhaupt lust haben mega
interessante kreationen die noa fischer
erbsen mit einer füllung aus kino und
avocado und hausgemachter rudow nämlich
so schieder nämlich besuch ist zu
kleinteilig stelle ein gericht das für
sich selbst steht ich denke das läuft
dann so wie ich mir die karte an schaut
auf eine bowle herauszoomen barabara bis
herbst ein kilowatt mp kirschtomaten
gurken in der mamablog arbeiterkammer
abgerundet und sesam los und cocktails
oder 16 euro 70 besser ist es gut
bestellt einfach
erste bestellung ist da genau 20 minuten
nachdem wir bestellt haben das schon so
ein richtiger großstadt traum so dafür
lohnt es sich zu leben und hier ist sie
wow ist schon sehr sehr hübsche
gelieferte essen oder dazu gibt es nur
schnäppchen aber erst der gedanke 16 eur
70 wird ja schon gefragt wie war das
essen das kann ich allerdings gleich
erst beantworten wenn ich es probiert
habe seitan bin ich erstmal sehr darauf
gespannt
dieses mussten ja schon so ein bisschen
berührt haben sehr sehr krass ist das so
ein bisschen phase rick hat so eine
schöne goldgelbe farbe schon sehr lecker
getrieben haben wir ein bisschen wacker
alten salat
ist laura ansonsten ist das einfach eine
mega bunte bau haben diese radieschen
blumen mini bridge street ist wenn die
weg wäre 60-70 so braucht schon
vielleicht noch 70 jungen also die
verrückt also das ist auch zu kommen die
in den kopf frei ist das im bull new
york
schmeckt er gut aber ohne soße relativ
wenig jetzt wo ich ja alle mal probieren
und avocado das ding ist wenn der ball
ist und leute wir das wollen bestellen
und selbst verbaut dann macht das schon
alles richtig weil der boden so
zusammengeholfen was vielen komponenten
die soße verbindet alles gut alles ist
frisch aber es ist jetzt keine
geisteskranke erleuchtung so bisher für
mich
wieso ist schon sehr gut 9 hype ich habe
mal kommen 620 apps sind schon fair ja
ja ja auf jeden fall also muss halt
immer überlegen dass du das bestellt für
mich selbst jetzt gerade mit hunger es
ist so eine acht aber wenn man darauf
bock hat ist es richtig richtig gut
damit auf zum nächsten ab zunächst eine
app wir sind bei lieferando der
klassiker der gigant unter den liefer
apps und als allererstes klicke ich
meinem verein rasiert und 638 ergebnisse
fünf sterne restaurants noch sechs maki
sushi und burrito take away ich habe
eine hoffnung 30 bis 55 ein bisschen
länger eine hoffnung und zwar dass es
keine normalen burritos würde mich auch
irritieren wenn ein laden sushi und
mexikanischen burritos macht horse ist
wie ich gehofft habe es gibt sushi
burritos das ist jetzt krank wie gregory
todschicken doritos ackergeräte und
endgeräte ich kann mir irgendwie
lachs burrito mit sushi dax stechen
nicht sogar vor wie schicken gurit um -
bringen japanischen brat hennig wähle
eine größere normal oder mega bisschen
im notfall dem mega wissen wir was mega
ist und sonderwunsch zitiert
dann haben wir es schon chicken fried
omega das war relativ schnell wenig
bands kommen sind da ist das ding mit
ordentlich extras für ein
mindestbestellwert haben wir hier
zwei regierung zwei bunkern sushi für
insgesamt zehn euro 80 das ist ja das
ist richtig hart an
ich schwöre ich hätte gerne waage hier
ich glaube das ding durch das delikt ein
halbes kilo denn die hat oder das ding
ist der favorit hat eigentlich ein
relativ niedrigen preis für top 12 euro
als mega version die wir sind relativ
teuer und haben es teuer gemacht aber es
ist ja auch das beste restaurant dass es
gibt auf der liste schon schön also mit
lachs ummantelt obendrauf auch so ein
feuriges tata aus leipzig innen drin
preis muss schon sehr gut schmecken ich
probiere
werbeträger lachs schönes schärfe von
oben drin der reichste auch perfekt
gekocht ich habe zuletzt das durch die
stadt ins zeug werfen da hab ich schon
sehr hohen standard jetzt eine gary cook
ich auch noch
ja vielleicht verliert
auch dabei dann kommen wir aber zum
eigentlichen star der show wollte ist
schon länger mal essen und tanz sushi
friedhof das schon mal gesehen nicht nur
auf instagram aktive ritus gesehen von
oben reinschauen erkennen wir
dann hätte ich nicht erwartet haben wir
auf jeden fall sehr ernst das nicht mit
dem modeblatt außen umgerechnet nein was
rap nicht so ich dachte und wusste das
es sowas werden könnte guck mal da die
favoriten einfach nur mal hoch
ist ein halbes kilo es mit 12 12 euro
das ist okay und ich mache für das geld
jetzt muss nur noch schmecken aber das
probiere ich einfach mal der erste
schritt meines lebens
crispy chicken hier in alter ist für
zwei personen das ist so ein apparat
fangen was haben wir noch mal bestellt
ich meine ich musste natürlich auch
wieder mega bestellen ist ja auch kein
salat oder wurstsalat drin wirst frische
dass verschiedene komponenten auch die
du drauf weist die sowieso gut
harmonieren weil es halt so sushi
komponenten sind dazu so ein paar
burrito einflüsse und mit richtig hunger
kannst du so ein ding glaub ich
verdrücken und es ist wieder so hast du
nicht danach wahrscheinlich nicht
komplett gefüllt das ist finde ich so
das produkt von verschiedenen trends die
so kombiniert worden sind fried josy
trend gurit trend einfach ein solches
gerät macht aber sieht richtig gut aus
und es schmeckt auch richtig gut jetzt
ist nur die frage kommt was besseres
dabei auch wie und wo reto kombiniert
ist also schiri tor besser als so steht
und besser als favorit für mich
persönlich ganz klar nein das ist falsch
das ist lustig um es mal auszuprobieren
aber ist jetzt nichts was ich immer und
immer wieder essen würde schon gar nicht
als mega version aber trotzdem ist es
lecker beladen ist auch gut für mich
persönlich ein bisschen schwächer wer
feiert gehört sehr viel spaß man ab zum
nächsten
let's go und ich schicke einen weiteren
kandidaten ins rennen ich glaube das
sind die drei größten aktuellen köln es
gibt noch kleinere aber 54 einnimmt bin
gespannt was hier platz eins ist ist es
erstmal wirklich interessant dass es so
verschieden ist also beim ein sushi
brite beim anderen veganer spot und hier
und wir filtern nach bewertungen
anwenden und ganz oben haben wir fein
fein healthy food köln irgendwie ist ein
motiv erkennbar so gesunde sache ist
gesund gesunde sachen wer häufig unter
den besten vielleicht wenn du es ist
wie herne bewertungen schauen wir mal
beim tesarek barry bigelow kini brown
dem sie schon mal direkt bestellen drei
protein schoko avocados capes und
süßkartoffel com ist mit pommes ist
schon eine interessante kombination dass
das schon super gesunde des rudels
zuglinien nudeln gibt es auch ich glaube
ich gehe wirklich auf diesen sap da kann
ich mir wirklich nicht vorstellen dass
er so krass geil sein soll leute ich
glaube dass unsere dritte bestellung wie
finanziere ich jetzt und dann sehen wir
zum probieren des finalen gerichts
nächste lieferung ist da wir haben low
carb zucchini brownies mit sind das
mehrwerte mehrwert durch den raum
tipp beim sap der
tatsächliche auf pommes serviert wer sie
sehr wild aus er sieht gut aus aber was
hebt ihn ab von so einem flughafen rap
dass die nährwerte also da weiß man
wenig das was man isst wenn du jetzt so
dass essen würde es bei einem anderen
burrito laden ja dann wirst du ja
niemals ihre kalorien das hat und für
manche leute ist das wichtig und ich
glaube aber dass sie das sich auch zu
marketingzwecken zunutze machen weil auf
zwei nachkommastellen wie gesagt dann
ist diese pommes hier weniger drin dann
habe es fünf kilokalorien weniger also
vom dinge wenn ich aber schon eine
handhabe
gebiete überdies hat vier euro gekostet
die maskiert das ist der roman die sein
vater weg nicht ganz so gut aber
irgendwie sowas in der richtung was ich
gehe mal rein
zweitens
ich würde sagen ja sehr lecker sehr
voller geschmack er macht auf jeden fall
die kommission einiges noch mal geil
geil das bin ich aber ihre aufgespannt
das ist jemand so zusammen tut man nicht
mal so viel wie so ein kleiner brito und
haben wir daraus möglichst und jetzt
packt den hammer aus stimmig so ein
klassischer lagen wir in so einem
bahnhof eigentlich sein könnte oder
sieht relativ normal aus dieser rap ich
meine sagt ja auch schon was ich sein
sollte
[Musik]
das habe ich der große unterschied zum
wirklichen flughafenbahnhof denke dass
er
sehr gut gefüllt auf jeden fall schicken
schmeckt super man schmeckt aber dass da
wirklich auch ordentlich parmesan drin
ist das ist frisch dann fühlst du dich
gut das schmeckt auch sehr gut und ich
fühle es komplett dass leute das
gefeiert ich probiere jetzt mal diesen
kompanie ehre hier ich habe schon mal
von zucchini brownies gehört tatsächlich
erst galt das ganz kalt ist es so sagte
ich merke dass kompletten der ist schwer
wahrscheinlich auch oder hallo ich mache
in stapelfeld jetzt auch auseinander
wenn es mein weiß aber ich muss es tun
[Musik]
also zucchini such so vergeben das
schmeckt überhaupt nicht nach zu wenig
man kriegt so ein bisschen mag haben
wenn man rein weist immer das mittel ein
bisschen schokolade händel
schokoladigen dass so eine gute
alternative zum richten trotzdem süß
trotzdem geil auf luftige konsistenz und
muss man erst mal so hinbekommen
182 kilokalorien dies nicht das ist
richtig wenig und er schmeckt so gut
dafür also da gehe ich komplett mit das
ist so richtig dass schon fast ein
bisschen zum mind blowing sondern ich
denke das kann ich essen und normaler
brauchen wahrscheinlich drei mal hier
ich muss wirklich sagen ich würde mich
nicht so leicht fallen ein gewinner
ausgewählt aus den teilen aber genau das
mache ich jetzt
ich finde ich bin auch schon mal krass
war mein favorit von den drei
verschiedenen läden die wir bestellt
haben bei jeder auf seine art bündnis zu
ersetzen ist waren aber nicht die besten
werden bei denen hier gegessen habe also
ich würde nicht sagen dass da auch meine
favoriten abgebildet waren die bei den
jeweiligen lieferservices gelistet sind
lieferung war bei allen eis essen war
gut quali war gut essen war frisch habe
den letzten platz macht für mich
persönlich der sushi burrito aber es ist
an sich auch eine geile kreation dann
kommt es jetzt schwierig dann kommt die
bauen auf ersten platz sind die raps und
der braune weil auf irgendwie keine
ahnung wie hat mich das über es gepackt
man fühlt sich locker danach richtig gut
es ist ein verdienter erster platz aber
nichtsdestotrotz wie gesagt gibt es bei
allen lieferservice sachen die ich
persönlich mehr feier- nummer eins geht
darf ein verein herzlichen glückwunsch
wir sehen uns zum nächsten video wieder
da werden wir einen ausflug in ein
anderes land machen kulinarisch und ja
bis dahin machacek könnte raten in
welches kleine raten welches ich gehe zu
verschlafen